nächstes kommen das ist wirklich ein
sagte kennt ihr beide okay die will ich
von euch eurosport wird kommt soll viele
leute ich habe heute die jetzt meiner
seite ich habe max an meiner seite und
wir spielen heute eine challenge zwar
bilder die man hören kann
doch erst klärte funktioniert das ganze
dieses ganze funktioniert so dass ich
euch beiden will das präsentiere sich
voll ausgeprägt aber wir treten gegen
einander antreten
der gewinner darf ein tag in meinem
leben bestimmt oh mein gott
ja ich wähle werden bild und wir müssen
den sound zusammen das weiß ich zeig
euch ein bild und sobald das bild da es
geht es darum wer als erster und wenn
beides zeit durchmache wir haben
meistens den ton zu den bären
verschiedene ganz krasse unterschied zu
bilden und es geht durch alles deutsche
- spiele alles gute
seid ihr wenn die leute ja mit du hast
wirklich bericht gespannt was das muss
aus der pistole geschossen kommt ihr
müsst ihn zugleich es korrekterweise
kommt setzt hören sicher sein
[Musik]
das war auch oder
natürlich würde es nicht sagen dass ich
mir damals also ganz vergleich auch der
fc ist hat in der hand du kannst
entweder das ist ein punkt auf der haube
machen das war ziemlich gleich das ist
einfach die beiden dann entweder
schlechter trip oder doch eher beim
nächsten das wollte die macht steht
jetzt das ok also das lösen der stecker
clubhaus statt
ich habe ja immer gesagt
trotzdem bist du im koffer sind immer
gleich ein hit i'll stand die leute es
geht weiter direkt nichts
eigentlich kann das jetzt ein neues
beschäftigen nicht mit
dazu gehört die ganzen satz der ganze in
diesem bild ist doch jammern heute
wissen hier im green lake und ich finde
das ganze ziemlich green day und den
finde ich persönlich ziemlich doch die
castro mottoshow richtung geht auch an
der 20
ein trauriges bild ist mit 32 1 also
sind sagt er
keine chance für ihn keine kalthoff
nicht aber es ist marianne rummel ich
erkläre etwas dazu doch ist jetzt in der
szene auf dem zimmer das total
verschmierte schokolade oder
zum braunen zurück oder kommt eine reihe
für das geld das kann kämpfen gehen was
ist denn hier los was ist denn je könnt
ihr nicht okay also ganz kurze anekdote
zu dominik das noch nie gesehen ich habe
da aber bereits in ried getroffen
auch lex diese andere pläne ich habe
sogar schon wir hier zu hause
der unterschied kann man sagt ja der hat
die kamera geführt bei interviews
lucanet noch mal gemacht hat genau wo
ich habe es schon was gesehen und egal
wie oft ich bin reich ist ja ich hab
mein prinz markus gesehen aber ich
wusste nicht welche art von gerät und
das ist genau das ich bin heilig
damit steht es 2 2 1 für dich okay
nächstes kommt teilweise war noch so
text ein drittes muss zensieren das ist
wirklich ein sagte kennt ihr beide okay
da will ich aus wird wulff ließ diese
bilder aber zu recherchieren
du dich besten okay es geht weiter
jung-star okay das ist jetzt wieder ein
bisschen mehr ausüben
frau ritter war so new school jetzt
kommt wieder ein bisschen mehr ausdrückt
wo ich mir nicht sicher bin ob du kennst
du kennst auf jeden fall glaube ich
vergeigt 32 kommt frei
dadurch würde ist nicht nur alles platt
zuerst muss ich überhaupt nicht worum es
geht aber dann habe ich nichts negatives
in die birs bauern kommt eigentlich
furchtbar
egal ich habe mich so traumatisiert wie
war das vor genau irgendwann hat das
soll dieses milieus oder getropft ist
auch wirklich erfüllt
und dann habe ich das gegoogelt und hat
mir das angeschaut wird erst aktiv wenn
leute damit steht es 3 2 und jetzt kommt
wieder ein neuer und das ist wirklich
auch uns gut des todes den muss
eigentlich jeder in deutschland kennt
die musik und hier alle 30 sekunden und
war anschließend nicht das ist im format
dialog natürlich fragen sondern werden
[Musik]
auf der packung steht 13 33 23 liga
sicher dass aber das ist doch klassik
oder das ist wirklich so verfolgt
classics von deutschen liebsten er war
und erst geht's weiter jetzt ein
bisschen andere kategorie
das ist wirklich meinen nein nein
das hat mir auch nicht ausschließen dass
leute nächstes bild es ist wirklich auch
ein weg womit ich viel verbinde was auf
meinen lifestyle ich persönlich liebe in
einer in einem visuellen element
zusammenfasst und ich möchte möglichst
viel text von euch dazu am ende könnte
ja die gleiche portion okay was kommt
jetzt
[Musik]
es ist ein zwei verschieden stadt nicht
weisst du hast immer sehr schnell
der typ der typ ist wirklich der
absolute gott von deutschen wie die
aussetzung nein der wahre gott ist an
alternativen zum video von polizisten
und ja das ist wirklich die leute
müssten rein zu wie ihr von polizisten
muss geht es darum wer die geschichte
von diesem typ x aufgezeigt der war
wirklich der butt zu kraft für
deutschland muss man sagen
seinerzeit einfach bei diesem video
haben alle übrigen gelacht aber seine
bizeps brennt mit der abrechnung ist
wirklich ein bild von der pds heute aus
respekt für die transformation und wir
machen weiter nächsten nächstes bild
ganz ganz klassisches deutsches leben
das gilt auch für den hodensack in
kaltes wasser fassen
da kommt ein anderes
definitiv definitiv nein
nächstes wirklich alle man kann entweder
wirklich für die leute ich will sagt mir
kann man bilder hören lass das nicht
gesagt ja nichts bekommt jetzt aber was
wir jetzt wollte ich diese dinge heraus
gesucht habe wir lacht man über solche
sachen gerade so bei ich muss raus typ
für die leute die selbst deutsche sind
ist das die hölle alter escada sei es
kann nicht wir gehen ja und wir tragen
dazu bei das video für mehr wo wir
gewesen sein laut motorblöcke also wenn
ihr diese menschen menschenleben trefft
denke man darüber nach und was die alles
schnell gehen sonst rüttgers der trieb
wir auch mit ich muss raus durchbricht
hat den anderen wurde ich gesagt habe
angetönt kind auch also das motto lachen
darüber aber ich glaube für die katze
mit hut sein nicht verhärten und das ist
was ganz also das tier biss hilfe
jetzt kommt es darauf an weg können wir
müssen gucken
ich wusste überhaupt nicht was gemeint
aber das hier ist mein gott er ist es
mir wie schuppen von den augen gefallen
als das gemacht jetzt ist er dort nein
aus der nächstes bild ist ganz ehrlich
was ich in meinem leben nie mitbekommen
habe das ist eigentlich und folgt gegen
deutsche kombinations trend gleich aber
den sound connection auch produzieren
wir haben hier sechs ok nichts bild hat
ich hoffe das ist haha das ist
eigentlich ein bild auf dem man fast
nicht sie aber ich bin mal gespannt ob
es tun könnte länger nach
[Musik]
nein gemeint mit den jobs wäre was dein
wird also ist einer der aktionäre und
nicht in die höhe oder indien so fliegt
jetzt so lautet auch in selb ich habe
gedacht dass ich bin dabei die luft
schon weit gefehlt wird dann verdammt
schwer sein wird diese vier jahren die
strafe ist das nicht zu einer besonderen
rüdiger nicht so tief wie gar nicht
gekauft und sich nicht so tief rüdiger
nicht so tief habe ich gesagt keine
kapriolen rüdiger bitte bitte bitte
[Musik]
leute wir haben einen gleichstand jetzt
kommt das entscheidende bild gelte heute
als gewinner raus geht und wir machen
ich werde ich einen tag lang nicht und
wir haben es hier drei zwei eins im
markt ausgezeichnet was wir heute
geleistet studien also hat in diesem
sinne bald wird ein video vom kanal
kommen wo max ein kommenden tagen
zustimmen bei mir bestimmt er wird mich
wahrscheinlich topf nehmen aber was
passiert bis der politik an diesem video
machte nächsten tagen folgen die kriegt
hier für euch vorstandes video hier
könnte man kann haben wir bisher aus
[Musik]